[Music]
and odd breaking news
no no reaction Oh crazy thank you it's
odd I'm not worried I'm trying to wait
for the odd part yeah yeah submitted by
Geo Rox
Hey a woman woke up to a strange man in
her apartment
what are you doing strange man you wake
got a strange man there what are you
doing in our house right now just taking
a shower
he's taking a shower ninja outfit oh
then I [ __ ] get the gun and then when
you blast is ask some questions I'm
asking question what do you say okay I'm
in there what do you do I'm a weird man
all right count of three you better get
the [ __ ] out that's not really a
question yeah I don't want to deal with
him different scenario man breaks into
your home takes taking a shower he's
also four foot three what do you do
oh I beat his ass beat up short people
about one see where you have the gun
already but you take it out you take it
all apart in the face and there you put
yourself in there yeah but let's put
Jason Chen in there Jason Cheddar's
taking a shower dude there's a part of
Bad Santa where Billy Bob picks up the
[ __ ] guy or he's a little 28-year old
woman from New York City woke up to an
unpleasant odor what are you gonna kick
him out yeah so she realized that
there's this stranger kissing her and
licking her feet oh no mouse his mouth
smells gonna stink
and that's all we got for that story
because I have nothing else they're
still looking for this man what fumbling
nothing she just woke up saw then he
just ran away so she grabbed his hands
and told them to get out and
get up stop stop doing things you didn't
have a gun and he did yeah he ran off so
he just didn't know that it wasn't
appropriate yeah so he's misunderstood
is what you're just trying to be polite
but he doesn't know how so he entered
this apartment building and started like
testing all the doors forgot I lock the
door and lock the door so you walked in
licked her face I got to start locking
my damn door well you don't like
anything I do lock my door from never
mind dude I mean this man that there is
currently looking for usually the Jesus
Christ I drink squash I was more for
Jesus Christ by looking good
yeah is that that dude that was looking
the [ __ ] doorbell was like going in
on that [ __ ] you really like that
doorbell dude oh my god dude oh so glad
that girl's foot in the car real hard oh
when he was driving there like older
white couple oh yeah yeah and they were
older my a couple of human X going to
town like that like you man she's just
chillin she was just like on her phone
just chillin he's just like like very
enthusiastic [ __ ] to her flip yeah
what is with that so yeah it had a red
light he told me she was an X cool used
to yeah suck on her [ __ ] foot and
then he would touch his belly button
while he's doing it that is so forgiving
no she said that's when sex said she
said yeah we she said that one sex tied
when the belly button came around not
the foot yeah so he was like let me suck
on your feet as I hit my belly play yeah
pretty much yeah and I think he was
probably finger banging his belly button
- lovely Rolly
so uncomfortable so he was a larger man
it was a deeper galley but yeah Jeff
what do you do you wake up this guy
licking her face you're home alone
scream and then the nut poke his
eyeballs out scratch em was it good I'm
not scared
[Applause]
you got your animals you what you guys
always resort to violence dude I don't I
wouldn't resort about how would you make
out back with him no I would politely
ask that he leave that he absconds it
excuse me sir
yeah no can you please stop doing that
and can you please remove yourself from
the premises thank you actually this was
a six a.m.
dude you know how I know I be this calm
because sometimes some [ __ ] will fly on
the middle of a road from like a truck
or something and I calmly just go
bit-bit like I don't like freak out
you're the sociopath we talked about I'm
calm under pressure dude I'm actually
like that seems like she'll scream like
there's like a yeah I'm just like okay I
feel the rush of things within my body
immediately simmers it all down well it
scares me about your driving though whoo
mine are his well you aren't driving is
pretty not when you go it's in the car
with you
everybody sees this car coming up right
but you what the craziest thing is you
actually look this way there's a
register that a car is there so you fake
everybody out in the cars I Bart knows
what he's doing no he's going the
talking scares me don't [ __ ] look at
me look [ __ ] straight have a good
conversation with you I'm saying I do
believe it because even as the cards by
the tea bonus he just goes whoa it's
interesting it's crazy
can you guys have a conversation and
drive at the same time yeah not well no
no no we can't
I slow down I start drifting around get
lost
yeah Casey always misses the exits he's
always swerve be like oh my god a little
baby one word you'd be like yeah guys
can't multitask no guys can't I can't
well he'll try and talk to me while
we're in the car and I'm like no you're
not allowed to speak to me free driving
you mean I just don't like it if I miss
an exit and it becomes a big ordeal you
know saying like you missed the exit is
to me unlike the conversations more
important exit I'll just turn back cause
I guess not we're in a rush at the end
of the [ __ ] earth I miss this exit
must be a girl thing then huh
yes I get that [ __ ] all the time to it
is that well you missed the exit I'm
like where we're going to McDonald's
relax you know it's like it's not a big
deal he's hungry yeah well we're going
to the Huntington Library to relax over
there so we can relax a few mistakes
it's okay there you go yeah but when
we've missed it every [ __ ] hundredth
time I'm like because the conversation
is so good no because we're talking
about the mystery I asked us earlier you
driving are you guys flying she goes no
we're driving to Vegas because Bart
wants to bond
they're so [ __ ] cute [ __ ] bail
bonds if you if you're in trouble I
wouldn't call that pill bonds ever - are
you calling bail bond that is [ __ ]
terrible
no thank you and there's filling Teleca
they're just too cute
it's too cute Oh Danny the better driver
then yeah [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
the terms of regular driving it's be
driving - I'm better do you know what
sucks do you want to go to a boat right
now I do
never
we recorded a picture I'd let you read
me I always I try I always try the first
round and then after that on the okay
quo I can all in these fools you can owe
me at every other round let's settle it
a k1 right now that's [ __ ] to it
[ __ ] JK we're going right now we'll see
you know every single track we've ever
been on snowboard surfboard four wheels
two wheels longboard bicycle I will own
your ass is so active it just exhausted
lighting fires shooting down planes
kidnapping children kidnapping our own
child releasing our child batches to
kidnap him again from her speed type but
we're really competitive are one of our
first dates was air hockey and uh
supposed to be just a friendly game but
also a fox species actual pretty good
I'm not playing [ __ ] like seven
rounds of it cuz we're trying to just
beat each other the whole time thank you
do me and Nikki we're playing Mario
Party and she's like [ __ ] you okay your
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude [ __ ] hate you I
hate you party we go in hard my good
side we go in so hard I wish she
wouldn't get that come play he keeps it
inside oh you want me to say that [ __ ]
it's coming up that's my favorite thing
between you two and when we do party
yeah it's always yours I used to be
dumped [ __ ] yeah we're very competitive
I believe it dude just I was on their
podcast just one little conversation
about a curly front fry and it exploded
he went in so hard I was so [ __ ]
pissed at her she's like curly fries are
crispy curly fries aren't crispy and I'm
like what the little [ __ ] talking about
Lilly fries are only Crispian
are you out of your [ __ ] mind she's
like third round so you know I'm like
that doesn't mean they're not [ __ ]
crispy the little ones the little was
the best she sat there and called us
both dumpling yes she was like you ever
seen a [ __ ] swing key before it's
made out of metal yeah it's still hard
still can bounce around you stupid
[ __ ]
is my favorite you stupid dumb pop it's
coming out cuz I like that I think that
chick I honestly think that Nikki is
probably a genius but she is so [ __ ]
stupid sometimes it just drives me up
Walden
mario party game and she feeds me by one
second and she's like [ __ ] put your
hands in the air and I picture myself
killing her driving to the [ __ ]
forest and and I'm like at least I never
have to hear her mock me again you
[ __ ] rough I know that's the worst
thing about both people right now sounds
like you've lost all [ __ ] [ __ ] to her
I [ __ ] suck at games
she just wrecks my [ __ ] all day and then
I put that but I'm so cocky that I'm
Michael I'm gonna get her next time and
then oh you're stupid I really do play
and think I'm gonna win this time and
then every time at the end of my but you
know what the difference is a guy would
let the girl wave so they can feel good
but a girl will never do the same what
sometimes we have feelings - we want to
win - yeah
but sometimes we don't get to because
it's a game what twists this is all one
big troll Steve actually cares let her
win cuz you're a sweet ass like that
Gina are you good at games I'm living
I'm decent she's being all she's a
professional that doesn't mean anything
I just saw a gamer if your average
person they will wreck the [ __ ] out of
you I think she's pricing she's decent
compared to the [ __ ] cross-eyed geeks
in there but Jesus self-professed titty
streamer so she doesn't have to be good
a game no no but you don't have to if I
was a teacher I think so much money
though oh really you're not a streamer
wait wait what's the tutoring you in a
TV streamer I don't really show my tits
like that's so stupid why don't you do
that in cuz it's morals but they're
they're gaming community I have some
morals you don't need more I want I want
certain sponsorships so I don't she has
a brain I'm not saying she doesn't
she said she did it and friends need to
know you have brains that everybody else
doesn't that's like if I called you
right now a titty news person is that
offensive because no because I have
titties right I use person a cheery
music person city news flaky it's not
bad huh yeah it's cuz you don't need to
be good at game cuz I'm like if I had
like if you got to that I'd be like [ __ ]
if I just like cuz I know me if I were
to just like you know what [ __ ] it I'm
gonna be a TV streamer and then I won't
be able control myself and now I'll
become like a stripper and a hooker well
it's just like I'm just too tired for
that oh you're like Mike Tyson about
like like these guys that complain about
you being a titty streamer they're gonna
look at you in the face they'll look at
you at your tits and apologize yeah
exactly
people just talk [ __ ] like I believe
that you cannot talk [ __ ] about things
that you actively consume so don't talk
[ __ ] about like oh [ __ ] porn stars
are all horrible I'm like you're jacking
off to them every [ __ ] like you're
the one providing this idea yeah exactly
that allowed it let's open the box
that's like all this Congress man don't
you that one congressmen who voted
against gay marriage and he's like
sucking to get all the signals reach in
his hand that's some congressman years
ago yes like a ten year think she's
Christ and then cake like how they
forbid from having sex within their
business what happens when you go with
[Music]